[MUSIC]
In this program of work,
we look at childhood obesity.
And we look at this important
challenge for two major reasons.
First, childhood obesity
is not just a problem for
developed countries like
we tend to believe.
It is actually a great challenge for
developing countries as well.
And this is because children in developing
countries tend to be both under nutrition
and over nutrition.
What it means is that,
they don't have access to whole grain,
great proteins options,
vegetables and fresh fruits.
But at the same time,
they have easy access to fast food and
sugary drink and those options tend
to be cheap and available everywhere.
The second reason why we want to study
this is because childhood obesity actually
has a long term negative consequence.
For the children who are obese
when they are young,
they tend to be obese as adults as well.
This affects their long term health, but
also, their psychological health, their
performance at school, and potentially,
their social interactions with others.
Obese children tend to
be bullied at school or
have a harder time making friends and
that could affect their well-being and
their relationship building.
And because of all these reasons,
we want to study childhood
obesity in this project.
[MUSIC]
I work in advertising before and I'm now
a faculty specialized in marketing and
I'm very aware that marketing
has been taken the bad name for
facilitating childhood obesity.
So we see a lot of fast food or
sugary drinks,
all these famous brands using marketing to
influence adults and children's behavior.
But what we are trying to do in this
project is to take a novel perspective and
to really think about what marketing is.
Essentially, what market is trying to do
is to communicate certain messages and
to influence people's choice.
So we could potentially use marketing for
the greater good of the society.
[MUSIC]
So we look at children in elementary
school from the first grade to
the sixth grade.
So usually that means they
are 6 to 12 years old.
Why we chose the school is because
school is actually the environment for
these children for the very first
time to make their own choice.
At home, they may not have a choice of
what they want to eat, their parents may
decide for them, but in school,
these children carry cash with them.
They get to actually make a decision
of what kind of lunch they
want to eat today or what kind of
snack they want to purchase today,
without the immediate influence from
their teachers or their parents.
So we believe that shaping
their behavior is important
because it is a very autonomous,
empowering decision for children
when they are choosing their own food or
drink for the first time at school.
So this is a great place to educate
them what kind of choices they
should be making that may be better for
them.
[MUSIC]
So in this research program,
what we did is we teamed up with UNICEF.
So we work for several years together.
We launched a five different field
experiments in various schools in
elementary schools in Panama.
And that allow us to enter the school and
try to communicate what is
healthy choice to children there.
So what we did in one program is that we
basically used the print ad concept and
we used print ads to communicate
what is drinking clean water.
So we educate and
promote clean water to children in Panama.
What we found is that by telling it as is,
basically educating them that drinking
clean water is good for their health.
Potentially, just having print ads in
school back grounds could be quite
effective in increasing
their water consumption.
And as a result, it could help to reduce
the consumption of sugary product.
In another program, what we try to do is
to use a very typical marketing tool,
price promotion,
to help promote healthy choices.
And this is because we tend to
have a perception that all healthy
products are cheaper.
So when we are trying to save money,
we may go with fast food or a cheap soda.
And we tend to perceive
healthy products as pricier.
Well, this might be true in some cases,
it is not always true.
So we try to use price promotion as
a way to provide another incentive or
motivation for children to pick
healthier snacks at school.
So we give them limited time price
promotion on healthy snacks, and
we track how much children actually redeem
those coupons to get healthy snacks and
as a result,
purchase fewer unhealthy snacks.
And importantly, we found that price
promotions can even be effective for
very young children age of six to eight.
Even for them,
they understand what it means to have
limited time to actually use a coupon.
They understand the concept
of a good deal.
And they may end up choosing or
purchasing a healthy snack at school
because this is on discount right now.
And hopefully by trying the healthy
option, they gradually built the habit and
preference for
healthier options in general.
[MUSIC]
This line of work can inspire and motivate
scientists from all disciplines to join
us, because for me, I come from a
background of advertising marketing and so
that is my tool for
trying to shape healthy behavior but
we believe that long term change
requires more than marketing.
We might be able to have price promotions
in a short run but eventually,
if we want to make sure healthy options
remain affordable and accessible,
we actually need more structural changes
on pricing the marketplace, tax, and
government regulation.
So we actually need scientist from all
different areas to help us accomplish this
and actually improve children's
health in the long run.
So I hope that this serves an inspiration
to start a dialog on what we can do
to help tackle this challenge.
[MUSIC]